[Musique]
comment les fournisseurs d'eau ont-ils
accompagné les collectivités les
industriels dont le robinet était à sec
cet été réponse avec vous Patrick béton
bonjour bonjour merci d'être là
président exécutive du groupe Sword
numéro 3 français la distribution et du
traitement de l'eau est-ce que vous avez
vous-même même si vous connaissez le
sujet été pris de cours par l'ampleur du
nombre de communes qui n'est plus une
seule goutte d'eau une centaine quand
même non alors je dirais que prix cours
non puisque le sujet de la transition
hydrique est un sujet que nous portons
depuis 3 ans c'était une de mes
convictions dès le début lorsque je suis
rentré chez sort parce que j'ai repris
la destinée de sort et je dirais que nos
7000 collaborateurs étaient sur le
terrain pour répondre aux collectivités
locales cet été c'est un été compliqué
mais qui était annoncé depuis plusieurs
années comment vous allez travailler
concrètement alors main dans la main je
sais pas mais avec les collectivités
pour faire face justement à l'urgence
quand il y avait plus d'eau dans les
dans les robinets on pense au
camion-citerne bien par ça j'imagine non
c'est la solution extrême oui certaines
villes ont eu des distributions je
dirais d'eau en bouteille pour une
grande ville dans un futur proche on a
du mal à l'imaginer on a du mal à
imaginer mais c'est une organisation qui
est mise en place à la fois avec la
préfecture avec la mairie et avec nos
équipes ceci valable je reconnaissante
des opérateurs sur le terrain nous avons
des des cellules de crise qui gèrent en
permanence et notamment sur la partie
estivale où nous avions de crise 24/24
chez sort qui nous permettait de de
gérer au plus près des collectivités ce
genre de souci quoi ce sont les
collectivités Patrick Betton qui ont
plus souffert que les industriels qui
peut-être ont souffert aussi d'ailleurs
les industriels ont moins souffert je
dirais
le véritable sujet en France si vous
voulez c'est quand on regarde la
consommation globale à
10%. vous et moi c'est 10% un petit peu
de cette consommation 20% l'industrie et
70% sur l'agriculture donc le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est l'agriculteur des
régions très agricoles ont dû faire face
je dirais
un manque de capacité parce qu'il
fallait aussi alimenter l'ensemble des
des productions agricoles et c'était un
progrès sur lequel on doit s'engager sur
lequel on doit travailler avec le monde
agricole juste un petit mot encore sur
cette plateforme info sécheresse pour
que les communes se préparent en amont
j'ai découvert en préparant l'émission
dites en plus là dessus info de
sécheresse donc c'est lié à cette
entreprise dont je vous parlais donc
imagéo qui nous permet de faire la
prédictabilité sur les ressources sur
les navettes phréatiques et d'orienter
c'est la consommation fonction de du
taux que nous avons sur les nappes
elles-mêmes et nous sommes en
déploiement total sur la France avec
cette on est dans le monde digital
prédictif encore une fois que ça
fonctionne
et qui a pu prévoir encore une fois les
trois épisodes de canicule qu'on a vu
cet été nous avons annoncé à ces taux la
difficulté de l'été que nous avons en
face de nous mais c'est un sujet qui
date de 10 ans je ne sais pas un sujet
lié à cet été l'été va nous permettre de
passer un nouveau cap d'un peut-être un
point de vue politique et de prise de
conscience mais le sujet de la rareté il
existe depuis très longtemps maintenant
après autre sujet il y a de la
réutilisation des eaux
usagées qui est aussi est incontournable
aujourd'hui ça sert à quoi
pour arroser des golfs et pour
ne pas s'arrêter là et en France où
est-ce qu'on en est ce qu'on est en
retard est-ce qu'on ne réutilise pas
l'eau assez lot pour justement cette
usager pour d'autres usages l'avenir
l'avenir passera par on est en France
là-dessus ce n'est pas un retard je
pense qu'il y a on a d'énormes très
contraignantes d'un point de vue
sanitaire on va peut-être au-delà de ce
qu'il faudrait on en fait quoi
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on utilise l'eau je vous
donne un exemple concret pour
aujourd'hui on est sur l'île de Ré donc
parler de l'île de précédemment sur
l'île de Ré on irait quelques hectares
de pommes de terre de l'île de Ré
justement avec de l'eau parce que l'on
appelle en anglais le riz donc c'est de
la route en français donc voilà donc on
avance sur ce sujet là mais on a encore
au niveau européen des écarts sur une
sur une même entreprise pour nettoyer
des chaînes de production en France on
va utiliser de l'eau potable et au
Pays-Bas je vais utiliser de du vous
êtes présent on l'a dit en Espagne au
Portugal en Arabie Saoudite évidemment
des pays où le stress hydrique est
beaucoup plus aigu que chez nous est-ce
que ça vous a permis ou ça vous permet
de développer sur place là-bas des
solutions qui vont servir chez nous là
aujourd'hui ou peut-être dans les
prochaines années dans le cadre de notre
[Musique]
leadership sur la transition hydrique
c'est un positionnement que l'on a pris
bien sûr que les technologies je dirais
inauguré dans certains pays nous
permettront de progresser en France mais
notre enjeu principal c'est surtout sur
l'industrie comment l'eau industrielle
le traitement des eaux dans l'industrie
va nous permettre à travers des
technologies d'amener via cette
technologie sur le municipal à travers
des membranes et autres parce que
l'industrie nous force à progresser
et donc nous amène à retravailler sur ce
sujet là donc en France on a beaucoup de
choses qui vont arriver prochainement et
après on finit là-dessus mais il y a
aussi la question du prix le prix l'eau
une ressource qui est de plus en plus
rare va forcément coûter de plus en plus
cher Patrick breton c'est inéluctable ça
il faut s'y faire comme les prix de
l'énergie comme
j'ai souvent dit par le passé que l'eau
n'était pas assez cher quand je dis
l'eau n'est pas assez cher c'est que je
pense qu'il y a pas de prise de
conscience sur la valeur de l'eau
aujourd'hui les collectivités ont besoin
d'investir les entreprises ont besoin
d'investir et je dirais que
la population a besoin de gérer
différemment gérer son quotidien à
travers l'eau et quand l'eau n'est pas
cher on ne fait pas attention je pense
que c'est important d'avoir ce
changement de d'habitude je pensais que
c'était théorème marqué les esprits
notamment des particuliers des ménages
des Français dans leur façon d'utiliser
l'eau certainement en haut il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un gros changement
et une prise de conscience qui a qui
évolue on doit continuer de travailler
là-dessus il y a un relais éducatif au
niveau de au niveau des écoles on doit
aussi aller dans les écoles pour
promouvoir la bonne parole mais je pense
c'est important de de d'accompagner
cette prise de conscience mais il y a
des grandes décisions qu'ils avaient
prises allez merci Patrick Gaëtan
président exécutif du groupe sors merci
à vous
[Musique]